g'day my name is Adam Kosh and this is
reto meier and welcome to this week in
Android development on Monday january
twentieth 2014 coming from beautiful
Sydney Australia over the past few weeks
we've been hard at work making Android
better faster and stronger and that
means another iOS lesson from todd is
todd ever going to run out of his i OS
lessons down lavelle covers his second
play bite talking about getting your app
priced just right and dannan Bruno
hosted game on talking about the google
play games plugin for the ever popular
Unity game engine magnus released two
dead bites the first introducing the
Google Drive Android API and the second
covering how to get started developing
quickly using this new drive API nieto
covered density-independent pixels in
his native tongue of Portuguese shifting
to this coming week on Tuesday Nazmul
has a new episode of UX design for
developers and Todd answers my earlier
question that no he will not stop the
constant barrage of play games on iOS
lessons neato covers responsive design
again in Portuguese antoni covers what's
new in Android 4.4 KitKat in Chinese and
in Cantonese and that's all for this
week in Android development my name is
Adam gosh this is reto Meier tie me
kangaroo down sport tie me kangaroo down
happy australia day